[Music]
it's time for et's social study a quick
look at everything your favorite stars
have been posting online are kelly
surprised Mariah Carey's Christmas
concert crowd in New York City Thursday
night
meanwhile Mariah's one-time Idol enamine
Nicki Minaj flaunted her figure in these
sexy snaps she's currently enjoying a
little R&R with boyfriend Meek Mill on a
couple's getaway in Turks and Caicos get
that pop in Jersey Shore star Ronnie
Magro is also getting romantic locking
lips on Instagram recognize the lady
with him no it's not Sammi Sweetheart
it's Khloe Kardashian's BFF Malika hock
the pair co-star on the second season of
the dating series a famously single well
Azalea is changing up her face again she
shared this kind of strange selfie while
getting a little work done she captioned
it just being a little weirdo getting
laser beams shot into my head and stuff
and Justin Timberlake is giving back he
surprised a performing arts school in
Australia with a singing at master class
while promoting trolls overseas you guys
are really special this is awesome for
me this was a real treat to get to hear
you guys and see you guys and so thank
you
[Music]
you